well let's take you to bristol now where
police and protesters have been clashing
following a demonstration against plans
to give police new powers to restrict
protests as you can see here things have
turned
violent as dark has fallen outside
bridewell
police station in the city center
thousands had gathered
earlier in the day defying current
covert restrictions before marching to
this police station
they've been graffitiing the side of the
building and police say
that missiles including a firework have
been thrown at them
and a number of police vehicles have
been set on fire
and attacked as you can see there we've
also been hearing reports that some
police officers have suffered suspected
broken bones in the last few moments
we've had a statement from avon and
somerset police they say they are
dealing with
a significant disorder in the city
center they say following a protest held
earlier today
several hundred people congregated
outside bridewell police station
during the afternoon chief
superintendent will white
the gold commander has said what started
out as a peaceful protest
has been turned by a small minority into
a violent disorder
he says these scenes are absolutely
disgraceful
and they will be widely condemned by
police across the city
they can never be any excuse for wanton
disorder
officers have been subjected to
considerable levels of abuse and
violence
one suffered a broken arm and another
suffered broken ribs
both have been taken to hospital these
are men and women
out there with the intention of serving
and protecting the public
they should never be subjected to
assaults or abuse in this way
at least two police vehicles have been
set on fire
and damage has been caused to the
outside of the station protesters are
not
inside the building let's bring in our
correspondent dan whitehead who joins us
there
uh live from bristol dan really truly
shocking scenes the kind of violence
that hasn't been seen on the streets of
bristol for
well dare i say decades yeah many years
indeed and there's no sign of this uh
protest ending any time
soon i'm stood i would say around about
30 meters away
from where the police found was on fire
you may would have seen the images
of that police van it said on fire that
the fire is now out but there are still
a number of protesters um on top of part
of bridewell police station which is in
the center of bristol there are
mounted police at the front of this
illegal demonstration i would estimate
that there are around
800 to around a thousand protesters
still
here um and plenty of police officers in
full riot here
i'm actually stood right next to a
police van which is covered completely
in graffiti it's light smashed at the
back
and a whole row of police officers with
riot shields
some of which have been sprayed with
graffiti
and words against the police all over
their actual
riot shield these police still holding a
line
i did for a moment go up to the front of
the
protest where the mounted police are
right by the
police station very lively uh atmosphere
up there a lot of music being played
clearly a lot of people who've been
drinking uh this is of course an illegal
demonstration that's gone on throughout
the day
and as that evening has gone on people
the tone of the protest has clearly
changed but this is very serious there's
a lot of smashed glass everywhere
fireworks have been set up in the street
but you can see the smoke rising in
front of bridewell police station
where that police van that was on fire
that is now
just about under control but clearly a
very serious situation which has
resulted in police officers being
injured smashed windows at the police
station and clearly
a situation which is far from over at
the
moment